YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Kubernetes is helping
develop our own
operations teams,
deploying more complex
applications than ever.
When rolling out a new release
or making other changes
to our production
services, we need
to make sure we're
prepared for any issues.
Stackdriver is Google's fully
featured operations management
[? feed ?] for
Cloud-powered applications.
Let's take a look at how it can
help you keep your applications
and services healthy.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you might have heard,
the Stackdriver team
has been working
hard to support using
Stackdriver with Kubernetes.
It's still in beta, but I'm here
today to give you a sneak peek.
The first and obvious thing,
we need a Kubernetes cluster
to monitor.
Let's create one.
And there is no
better or easier place
to do that than Google
Kubernetes Engine, or GKE.
Now, the beta feature is only
available for clusters running
Kubernetes version
1.10.6 or later,
so let's create one of those.
Here's the gcloud
command we're going
to use to create our cluster.
Note the enables
Stackdriver Kubernetes
flag that opts us into the
beta monitoring and logging
features.
We also need the
cluster-version=latest flag
to make sure they run
a supported version,
at least 1.10.6.
Once the cluster
is up and running,
we'll want to see exactly
what's running that.
And what better way to do
that than with kubectl.
We have the monitoring and
logging agents, the metadata
agent, and heaps are all
running in a Stackdriver agents
namespace.
These will collect
all the details
we need from our nodes
running in the cluster.
Now that we have a cluster
with monitoring set up on it,
let's take a look at the data.
When we go to Stackdriver
by clicking on Monitoring
from the Products
and Services menu
and look at the
Resources menu, we
can see a new entry
called Kubernetes beta.
This is the new
Kubernetes monitoring UI.
Let's take a look.
The first thing you'll
notice is that we
have three different ways
of looking at our cluster.
The infrastructure view may be
more useful for understanding
the physical layout of
your cluster, nodes,
and what's running where.
The workloads view
is more relevant
if you care about what's
running in the cluster
and namespaces more so
than about the nodes.
This may be relevant
for folks responsible
for the applications
and services,
such as the DevOps teams.
And finally, the
services view can
help you understand how
workloads in the cluster
are exposed as services, load
balancers, ingress controllers,
and the like.
And this might be most
relevant if you're
attempting to troubleshoot
an issue, attempting
to communicate with the
services running on the cluster,
and don't necessarily
need to know about what's
behind the services themselves.
Note that every view allows you
to click on any of the elements
to get more details about them.
You can see things like
open incidents affecting
that particular
component, other events,
such as container restarts,
and performance and utilization
metrics.
Even logs are integrated into
this view for easy access.
Now that our cluster is up
and monitoring is in place,
we can use Stackdriver to ensure
that our application stays
healthy.
Come back next time
when we use Stackdriver
to identify, triage,
and diagnose problems
on our application.
That's it for this episode.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]